well now it all makes sense
you know before with the first episode
with the slumber party that was weird
and I couldn't really figure out
anything but now we have trouble in
lumpy space and this is where it all
comes together this is where all the
questions that were raised in the first
one suddenly are answered I mean it's
like the ending to lost that we never
got it's like wow all these things we
were questioning this is one of the
strangest things I've ever watched and
it's disturbing and unsettling but cute
at the same time and it frightens me and
the idea that I have to watch like 60
plus more of these frightens me even
more I guess I'll talk about the story
okay so Princess Bubblegum meets with
Princess of lumpy space well I'm not
actually sure is female sounds very male
is just this big lump of I don't know
what and they're like oh let's uh did I
accidentally bite the dog Oh what I'm
eats he's gonna turn lumpy unless you go
into lumpy space and get the antidote
from these soft guys and the way to get
the lumpy space is through a frog who
eats them and lumpy spaces in the Frog I
guess so so the the lumpy Space Princess
goes to her parents who do not look like
royalty they just look like two random
parents and they have to get to makeout
point that's where the antidote is they
get there but the dog turns into one of
the lumpy people
because again bitten by princess lumpy
and that's what the lumpy people do it's
a condition and apparently he becomes
one of the lumpy people which I guess is
like deep throated Valley girls if they
ate a bunch of marshmallows and tried
talking it makes about as much sense as
anything else
and he pinned the boy with the weird
panda thing on his head goes and tries
to bring this sphere which apparently is
the antidote that you have to sit on to
the dog and he turns lumpy in the
process because he gets bitten but then
they both sit on it and they're okay and
that is the episode
I've never seen anything like this
this is like like even Ren and Stimpy
which is a show that I love and was very
surreal and I just ate up the surreal
nosov it but it was simple you could
follow it enough and that didn't always
have like an introduction that made
sense sometimes they lived in the house
sometimes they lived in a tree it just
varied this at least is consistent with
its strangeness it seems to always take
place in the same world but it's just so
constantly throwing oddness at you and
it's so doesn't care if it entertains
you maybe in a strange way that's why
people find it entertaining cuz it's
just sort of doing its own thing and
clearly doesn't give a what any of
you say about it
ironically resulting in it being a big
hit and everybody loving it so this is
like some sort of mad genius formula
that somehow they've cracked and made
tons of money on both trying really hard
and not trying in the least it's the
most bizarre combination of elements and
elements
the only other thing I can think about
to say about it is that you know I do a
panel on comedy and a lot of these
conventions and it's one of the things I
talk about a surreal humor right so
surreal humor is wonderful you know my
Python does lots of really humor gamer
and Stimpy does a lot surreal humor but
the downside is that a lot of it leans
towards surprise you know did that it's
the it's the comedy of the unexpected
but when you have a show that keeps
going and you keep throwing in
unexpected stuff it's tricky because
then you can start to see the unexpected
jokes it gets in the formula so it's not
that can't be done is that it's
incredibly difficult to do and to this
shows credit even I'm only on Episode
two I don't think you could start any
episode and have any iota of thought
where it's going to go or how it's going
to end up or what kind of joke is coming
it is that desire and everything in it
looks bizarre and act bizarre and talks
bizarre and there's just I think because
there is no lead-in there's no setup
there's none of that it just sort of is
it doesn't give you I guess it doesn't
give you a framework to get used to it
doesn't give you anything to be like oh
well I know this is gonna happen cuz
this is the kind of world that set up
you know even Ren and Stimpy you know
have a setup they're gonna be firemen
well obviously a building's gonna burn
they're gonna try and save the people
and it's gonna backfire or something or
you know Ren's going to a psychiatrist
well obviously it's gonna go tell his
story and you know he's gonna find out
why he's crazy none of that you can't
predict anything in this show like
anything and it is funny I I laugh but
it's like that uncomfortable laugh where
like am i watching something really
ingenious or phenomenally stupid or both
I don't know I've
I've never seen anything like this it is
so consistently throwing strangeness at
you but somehow not reaching that level
of annoyance somehow not being like okay
god they're trying too hard or whatever
it's just sort of the right kind of
strange balance and I don't know what to
think of it I I think it's good it's I
apologize these that these are not very
good not very good because it's like but
can you blame me it's like how can
anyone talk about this kind of thing
it's like it's um I'm doing the best I
am doing my best and I don't know maybe
these V vlogs will just turn into what
the show is turning into just like a
plate of madness I don't know just
trying to describe it trying to figure
it out but I will not give up okay
because this show is a hit it has so
many fans it has a lot of people that
love it and love talking about it and
quoting it and we have to figure out why
we have to bring some understanding to
this madness you know what this is gonna
be like therapy like I'm the
psychiatrist and Adventure Time is the
person who is clearly insane and I'm
just trying to figure out the method in
the madness and why it enjoys the
madness it wants to stay in the madness
was the attraction to the madness while
possibly being drawn into the bandhas
myself but I'm gonna be a good
psychiatrist here I'm gonna try and keep
one foot in reality and one foot in this
bizarre scary realm that's been put in
front of me so okay says so next time
I'm hoping to have more of a
understanding and more of a method of
addressing this because I just don't
know I just don't know I mean about
anything right now this show has put me
in a bad spot or maybe I'm confusing it
for advance by me HS a spot I'm not used
to but there's lots more to go and
chances are you'll see me break but I'm
gonna try my best not to I'm gonna try
my best to make sense of this and talk
about what what's good about it what's
bad about it because I've never come
across something where I can't really
say what's good about what's bad about
it because it's not giving me that it's
just sort of giving me what it is and I
can't as a reviewer we want to put these
things in categories I'm not saying
that's good but it's what we're used to
it's and the niver view is just people
this is what we do we like to put things
out or this is a good category this is
the bad category and we like to separate
things and that's just and this show is
really challenging that and probably
good for it but it's a confusing time
okay it's it's a confusing strange time
to go through and I'm gonna stick it out
though it's only episode two but I'm
gonna stick it out and we're gonna
discuss this and we're gonna figure it
out we're gonna get through this
together so I'm sorry I think these are
going even longer than the episode but I
just I gotta figure it out I gotta
figure it out I'll be more together in
the next one